the russians have clearly reassessed
their objectives in the war focused
primarily on the east
their major problem is that they have to
reconstitute enough what we refer to as
combat power the ability to fight
effectively in the east and then take on
a very entrenched and very experienced
ukrainian force that has been preparing
for them for a long time
so the next three weeks will be decisive
it will determine the outcome of the war
and if we the west can increase our
sense of urgency in supplying the
ukrainians perhaps up to the level of
the berlin airlift the ukrainians can
really come out of this with a victory
uh i believe the u.s national security
adviser jake sullivan um saying that he
expects russia's newly appointed
general to be either i think his name is
alexander duromnikov
to be even more
uh bloody and determined to break the
soul of the ukrainian people
yes i agree with that assessment the
russians are medieval they're brutal but
they're not stupid and so they learn and
they've learned quite a lot about how
the ukrainians are fighting so i believe
the general will go back to classic
russian tactics they'll do massive air
and artillery assaults on the ukrainian
positions
before they throw a lot of tanks and a
lot of soldiers at them but it's going
to be a difficult proposition for them
because we just don't assess that they
have the energy to be able to carry off
that sort of campaign and it will cause
a lot of brutality as president zlinski
has predicted it'll look like world war
ii as the ukrainian foreign foreign
minister said
at the end of the day the russians are
going to suffer even more casualties in
this approach
we continue to hear that uh president
putin
wants to de-escalate the situation in
ukraine should we believe him
well frankly i don't believe so because
the negotiations are now at a state
where neither side really feels they
have a strong position
and war is a continuation of policy by
other means and president putin's policy
obviously is the subjugation of ukraine
and so anything that he says
that tries to disguise that fact would
not take
as truth
so given that you were previously the
assistant defense secretary for europe
and nato what's what's your
interpretation of what his plan is
what's his end game
well i think given the success of the
ukrainian military his endgame is
shifting his personal end game has to be
to stay in power and i think we have to
look at everything that he does through
the lens of that because he doesn't have
a lot of other options once he leads
government in russia and so his end game
is to stay in power which means he has
to play to the domestic audience which
means he has to come out of this with a
victory and so enhancing the position of
the russians in eastern ukraine
in
essentially the russian speaking areas
of ukraine by taking a land border a
land bridge if you will from the
donbasque down towards the black sea and
enhancing the overall state of the
russians ability
to claim that they're supporting russian
speakers in ukraine i think will be
enough of a victory for him
to consolidate his gains sue for peace
achieve some level of
sanctions relief through negotiation and
then wait us out wait a few years and
try again
is that too much of a defeat for
zolensky though
yes kay i do believe it is i can't see
any negotiated settlement that results
in the ukrainians giving up even more
territories being acceptable uh to
president zielenski and he has rightly
said whatever negotiations result
he has to put that to the ukrainian
people for their support
and i don't think they'll ever accept
that
um
in the meantime i was looking at
pictures of our own prime minister
actually who was
in kiev at the weekend
we know that your president president
biden is hoping to speak to the leader
of
india president modi
we also know that india is still an ally
shall we say of russia and taking cut
price fuel from russia
do you think that president biden
speaking to modi will make any
difference at all to the relationship
between india and russia
well i think we're in this situation
with india of incremental changes over
time the indians are geographically
situated between the chinese the
russians and the west and they're being
very careful on how they're hedging
they clearly need the support of the
west
in their comp competition with china and
they balance
their relationship with russia to be
able to maintain a level playing field
if you will from their point of view i
think president biden will have some
influence the united states and the
europeans have a great deal to offer the
indians and the indians are being very
coy as to how they're going to position
themselves for the outcome of this
conflict but i think very gradually
president biden's influence in the
influence of
prime minister johnson and other
european leaders i will bring the
indians more on side as they see that
the ukrainians are going to come out of
this
war with the russians in a better
position
okay we appreciate you i don't know
getting up early or staying up late for
us i'm not sure which one it was but
either way we do appreciate it here on
the program this morning thank you
thank you very much